wusstest du dass du selbst auf einem
winzigen Balkon oder in einer ganz
kleinen Ecke im Garten deine eigenen
Kartoffeln anbauen und richtig viel
ernten kannst ich zeige dir in diesem
Video wie du Kartoffeln in Kübeln oder
pflanzsäcken anbaust und worauf es
ankommt damit du dann auch eine richtig
dicke Ernte einfährst ich habe zum
ersten Mal vor ungefähr zehn Jahren
Kartoffeln in Pflanzgefäßen angebaut und
da war meine Ernte noch alles andere als
dick aber mit den Jahren habe ich dann
rausgefunden worauf es ankommt wenn du
Kartoffeln im Topf anbauen willst dann
dreht sich alles um drei Dinge die Du
unbedingt beachten solltest Part 1
dieser Kartoffel Gleichung ist dass
deine Pflanzen genug Platz haben müssen
um überhaupt viele dicke Knollen
ausbilden zu können also her mit den
Pflanzgefäßen dafür kannst Du quasi
alles nehmen hauptsache das
überschüssige Wasser kann nach unten
abfließen falls dein Gefäß keine Löcher
hat dann boah einfach welche in den
Boden am allerwichtigsten ist dass das
Gefäß ein Volumen von mindestens 20
Litern hat wenn das Gefäß kleiner ist
bleiben die Kartoffeln nämlich auch
richtig klein und vor allem die Pflanzen
dann viel weniger Knollen aus außerdem
sollte das Gefäß eher hoch als flach
sein weil wir unsere Kartoffelpflanzen
in den nächsten Monaten immer wieder
Anhäufeln werden was das ist erzähle ich
gleich noch ich habe euch ja schon
erzählt dass wir hier an unserem Büro
einen Balkon haben den wir dieses Jahr
richtig schön machen wollen und richtig
vollpflanzen wollen und das ist für mich
natürlich super weil ich auf meinem
Balkon zu Hause nicht filmen kann weil
man dann sieht wo ich wohne und deswegen
drehen wir jetzt hier ganz viele
balkonvideos für euch also gern
abonnieren wenn ihr das nicht verpassen
wollt wir haben uns jetzt hier für
Pflanzsäcke entschieden es gibt auch
Pflanzsäcke die eine Öffnung haben so
dass man die Kartoffeln dann später
leichter ernten kann aber du kannst
natürlich auch Blumentöpfe nehmen oder
vielleicht eine alte Zinkwanne was auch
immer du da hast solange das Volumen
passt und dann brauchen wir natürlich
noch die Kartoffeln Kartoffeln aus dem
Supermarkt können mit Mitteln behandelt
sein die die Keimung hemmen und ohne
dass die Kartoffeln keimen können Sie
natürlich auch nicht wachsen deswegen
solltest du entweder Pflanzkartoffeln
nehmen oder einfach Kartoffeln aus dem
Bioladen es ist ganz wichtig dass du
darauf achtest dass die Kartoffeln die
du nimmst keinen Schorf auf der Schale
haben und nicht beschädigt sind der
perfekte Zeitraum um Kartoffeln zu
pflanzen ist im April und im Mai vorher
kannst du deine Kartoffeln ungefähr für
drei bis vier Wochen in dem hellen und
kühlen Raum vorkeimen lassen so dass sie
richtig schön kräftige grüne oder
violette Keime ausbilden das ist je nach
Sorte unterschiedlich weil wenn du die
Kartoffeln dann raus pflanzt dann haben
die schon einen Wachstumsvorsprung von
den paar Wochen das ist aber absolut
kein muss also wenn du jetzt spät dran
bist mit dem Pflanzen dann pflanzt die
Kartoffeln einfach so in die Erde das
klappt auch apropos Erde und hier kommen
wir zu part 2 der Kartoffel Gleichung
Kartoffeln sind richtig hungrig deswegen
solltest du eine torfreie Bio Gemüse
Erde verwenden die es nämlich schon
etwas aufgedünnt kartoffeln haben
wirklich einen hohen Nährstoffbedarf und
deswegen füllen wir das Pflanzgefäß als
erstes zu ungefähr einem Drittel mit
Erde auf und damit unsere Pflanzen mit
allen Nährstoffen versorgt sind die sie
brauchen mischen wir dann noch
zusätzlich einen bio-dünger Schafswolle
mit in die Pflanzenerde ein du kannst
auch einen Klee Dünger nehmen oder
Hornspäne und dann kommt die Kartoffel
in das Pflanzgefäß richtig in ein 20
Liter Gefäß kommt nur eine einzige
Kartoffel wenn du größere Gefäße hast
dann kannst du natürlich auch zwei
Kartoffeln legen und dann bedeckst du
die Kartoffeln mit Erde und drückst die
Erde vorsichtig an aber pass gut auf
dass die empfindlichen Keime nicht
abbrechen falls du deine Kartoffeln
vorgekeimt hast dann das ganze erstmal
mit viel Wasser angießen das ist
besonders wichtig wenn die Erde noch
ganz trocken ist im April und Mai ist es
oft ja noch ziemlich kalt deswegen ist
es sinnvoll wenn du die Pflanzgefäße mit
einem Winterschutz fließt abdeckst und
von jetzt an und das ist Part 3 der
Kartoffel Gleichung solltest du deine
Kartoffeln immer so Gießen dass die Erde
nicht komplett austrocknet aber sie
sollte auch nicht für längere Zeiträume
pitschnass sein da muss man also den
perfekten Mittelweg finden und bevor du
dich jetzt fragst oh mann woher soll ich
denn wissen ob ich jetzt zu viel gieße
oder ob es vielleicht gar nicht
ausreicht wie viel ich diese fast
einfach die Erde an wenn die sich
anfühlt wie ein drückt der Schwamm dann
ist es perfekt unsere Kartoffelpflanzen
haben jetzt angefangen auszutreiben und
so ganz kleine grüne Blättchen gebildet
und wenn die so ungefähr 15 cm groß sind
dann können wir Anhäufeln das bedeutet
dass wir dann noch mal 10 cm Erde in den
pflanzsack reinpacken oder in das
Pflanzgefäß reinpacken und die Blätter
dann nur noch 5 cm oben rausschauen und
das können wir dann wenn die wieder 15
cm groß sind noch mal wiederholen bis
unser pflanztag voll ist Kartoffeln
werden nämlich grün wenn sie dem
Sonnenlicht ausgesetzt sind und bilden
dann Solanin und das ist für uns
Menschen giftig und wann sind die
Kartoffeln dann endlich fertig und wann
kann man ernten also wenn das Laub
komplett abgestorben ist dann ist das
ein gutes Zeichen dafür dass du mit der
Ernte beginnen kannst außerdem kannst du
dir die Kartoffelknollen dann mal
anschauen die sind Ernte reif wenn Sie
eine feste Schale haben außer bei
Frühkartoffeln die kann man auch ernten
wenn die Schale noch ein bisschen weich
und Papieren ist falls du einen
Gemüsegarten hast und Lust hast da auch
kartoff ELN zu pflanzen dann schau mal
hier drüben vorbei da zeige ich nämlich
eine Technik wie man mitten auf dem
Rasen Kartoffeln pflanzen kann und so
auch neue Beete für andere
Gemüsepflanzen in den nächsten Jahren
anlegen kann und trotzdem noch eine gute
Kartoffelernte hat also schau gerne
trieben vorbei und dann geh raus auf den
Balkon oder in den Garten und macht die
Welt so viel grüner und wir sehen uns im
nächsten Video wieder bis dann tschüss